piano at your mom my mother your mother
and she was English wasn't she yeah and
she was a costume designer yeah she was
yeah but we've got a pitch she
apparently oh my gosh I know she
designed what dolly is wearing on this
wow I love this show
this outfit was in your house oh yeah
yeah I I wore that for Halloween
you're not joking are you no
the body is famously I mean how did you
there was some rub right yeah where did
you go wherever did you like did you go
door to door did you Trick and Treat him
well I wasn't like 14. you know I was
16.
what did I do I got on public
transportation well the thing was I
didn't have the shoes so I had that
whole thing I had the ears I had the bow
tie I had the top I didn't have the
cufflink and then it was the stockings
that I didn't shave my legs and I was
wearing these really ratty sneakers and
then I was on the streetcar going to
this uh fat Halloween party at the
performing arts high school that I went
to and did you have this with you I was
wearing it it was Winter I was there I
was like nobody you'd have to have this
with you so people knew just how cool
your costume was I know it was well man
yeah
can't no no no come on
attention
where did you guys find this it's mine
I've tried it for your motorbike
I fell off that
[Music]
on Silence of the Lambs is it true that
did you never speak to Anthony Hopkins
no never spoke to him he was scary
I mean the first day we had a reading we
had like a little read through and we I
got up there early and then I went to
the bathroom and I came back everybody
was sitting down we did the read through
the of the film and by the end of it I
never wanted to talk to him again I was
trying to find it
um and so then we did the whole movie he
was always behind those the glass
partitions or he was in his cell and
because the scenes were so long they'd
kind of lock him in at the beginning of
the day and he'd go there and then the
next day he'd be on the other side and
I'd be and I'd be on this side and we
got to the end of the movie and it
really had never had a conversation but
you never passed backstage in a car no I
avoided him
you've now forged this you know career
as you know you know it's the scream
Queens Curtis but then your mom Janet
Lee I know famous I mean she was the
original screen in Psycho yeah and so
was it weird that your first movie was
going to be a horror yeah yeah
but you know the truth of the matter is
it's just a fun curio but horror fans
are as loyal as yours and when you were
talking about how you felt when those
people I am on what I call
affectionately the Victory lap European
tour for Halloween I'm just going around
high-fiving everybody I meet because the
same things with horror fans the same
exact thing the amount of love and
appreciation for these movies I don't
know why people like to be scared but
when you were talking about it it made
me I was sitting here thinking that's
exactly how it feels to be in a
Halloween movie they love it and they
show their love back to you with this
tremendous love and support for these
stories that they seem to love so in the
exact same way that you felt that
gratitude with your bandmates I feel it
on my Victory lap jlc around the world
tour which I'm in the middle of and
having a blast you don't like these
films
sorry guys
support the film Tom
when it comes to this kind of thing I
would be the worst horror movie director
you could imagine no but no but that's
weird because John you didn't like these
films no not at all I I think the
technical term is a scaredy cat
yeah I first saw horror movies growing
up uh I was too terrified and obviously
I'm a huge horror fan now if you saw my
iTunes list over the last year you'd say
I think we have a problem
um but it's uh it's phenomenal I don't
think I'm my name is the one that you
see and say can't wait to see a horror
movie from that guy but the original
script came to me and it's actually uh
an incredible story of family and so
it's to me you can't tell by looking at
the poster we can show that again but it
is a love letter to my kids it's about
what would you do as a parent what
extremes would you go to to protect your
kids and is this true that this film you
originally weren't going to be in well
we had just had our second child and I
was about to do Mary Poppins and so I
was in a sort of general feeling of Joy
I didn't know if I wanted to go towards
the darkness of the pitch that he'd
given me for this film and then I I'd
mentioned a friend of mine too John when
he bitched me I said oh you should call
so-and-so and um and so-and-so is so
good
so he did call so-and-so and you didn't
send her the script admittedly she
wasn't sort of hired but um
and then I read the script and I was
like you need to call her and fire her
still friends with her we are until the
movie comes out and then she's like
because normally it was something so
kind of computer animation and all that
sort of stuff yeah there's a lot of
green screen and stuff but you actually
went to locations yeah I do think
actually it's the great uh Jordan but
Roberts who directed it really was
insistent that we go to places on Earth
which are both beautiful and dangerous
um so that it didn't feel like a digital
environment it felt like a real place so
we went to Oahu in Hawaii
the
umbrella blew out of my cocktail
um we went to Queensland in Australia
that's scary I'll give you that they're
a rainforest there and they have the
most
um or the most dangerous animals in the
world are in the state of Queensland in
Australia yeah crazy yeah um snakes
spiders some Queens are going yeah I
escaped um
you know you'd see the final Web spiders
starting to Jesus
had come to Australia they've got this
you're right they've got the most
poisonous spiders snakes jellyfish
sharks crocodiles and they walk around
in flip-flops yeah
no that's why that's why women men yeah
they have to they have to they're
fighting for their lives yeah you had a
proper terrifying encounter the sort of
thing Kevin would not like this yes
so I'll try and speak slowly so that
everyone
so we were filming in South Africa and
unbeknownst to me the uh some of the
South African crew had been filming what
is known as a sack spider uh crawling up
and down out of this tree so the sac
spiders in the tree they're filming it
filming each other I've got footage
saying this is terrifying look how
terrifying that is no one told me I run
out of the uh the building everything's
a secret it's like I'll tell you what
building I run out of the building Into
the Wilderness as this sucks spider just
crawled down you got down
[Music]
I'll absolutely break it and cannot
repeat what I said costume was off and
our first aid the first assistant
director was English
pretty casual I just picked it up and
chucked it it's all the South Africans
went no no no
and then we found out I could have died
wow I didn't it didn't even
if you Google a sack Spider by it is
awful so that is a better story is it
ugly it's like got a really big body and
it's got a big box but it was a sack
s
everything has to be explained to you
like you just don't understand
it's got poisonous balls keep going
is making the story a bit different
are you so the spiders balls
we asked the audience about their
biggest fears and uh let's let's just
delve amongst before you say anything
Ruffalo will take you down
okay okay so hands up if you've got a if
you've got a fear we asked me book uh
it's a nice lady here what's yours um
I'm actually afraid of sperm in places
it's not supposed to be
what your forensic scientist yes
so but but where I find it in really
weird places and I feel like it's
everywhere and it freaks me out I think
you should have your couch checked out
[Applause]
I'm good you're good well actually I'll
tell you what I tell you what what I've
got I've got one of those little CSI
things
men are now thinking
foreign
okay so what's your name Dean okay come
out here Dean put your hat down okay
stand up there okay okay let's bring it
let's bring the lights out let's bring
the lights down let's bring the lights
down
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
um
it does to like people and even this
Halloween uh so people were dressing up
as Moss from the I.T crowd and uh but
you might have you must have seen this
picture there was a little girl do you
know this well look it's a cheap costume
it's a check shirt
don't Dash her dream I will not this is
a little girl in America and she's a big
fan of her Halloween she went as Moss oh
look at that
look at the what she's got the computer
the calculator watch and everything yeah
that's good right the emotional range is
too large though
he's a kind of dial it back
I also spoke to her
I said you've got to get there
can we just say how pleased we are that
Bill's here at all because there was a
time when you were dead that's right
what yes because I know I'm looking a
lot better now
yeah I know that's right there no well
this is I'm I'm sure that this is
referring to the fact that uh I was
mistakenly reported as dead on the BBC
website
I know it was a BBC website and um it
just said uh tributes uh pouring in for
actor and comedian musician Bill Bailey
who has died at the age of 52 which is
really annoying because they've got the
age wrong firstly I was so annoyed about
that and they use a weird photo as well
I mean what is that I think
that is perfect for an obituary that is
that says that says this sucks
here is dead Daniel the whole time
it's like it's weird because it's like
it's like he's it's like he's dead
no
will he sit up not really
so yeah
um touch his hand touch his hand
so creepy yeah that's that's weird
he really is sort of falling apart at
this point but he's been sent down
Rivers he got mauled by a bear like this
was all things we did to him during
filming and that's really good though
look at the look at the look at the the
eyebrows yeah
[Applause]
but just it's strangely horrible I don't
know I don't know what's happening to it
at the end of the press tour so if
anybody you know wants it
maybe not actually
you could not have this
yeah I have an infamous picture of me
um in my 20s and I was just owning this
look I had a turtleneck I had mom jeans
on I had I was wearing a fan we've got
the picture here oh no there you are
and this was this was you being serious
yeah no oh yes I think I'm cool
and are you aware that this has now
become a sort of fancy dress outfit
and people do this they do this yeah as
a joke yeah it's crazy Seth Rogen was on
the show yeah and he showed us his
version here's Seth Rogen as it
that's my guy that there's just a random
man but very good eye for detail see
he's got the tissue the tissue under the
elbow which you have here it's because
let me just give the audience context is
what that is the the what I have my arm
on was very dirty so I thought I need a
tissue please to protect the turtleneck
that's it you must have a beautiful home
no young fans are attracted to it as
well
[Laughter]
I love the Rolex the tissue yeah and
actually uh some other people have done
it as well yeah check this out
oh yeah
look at that I want a party got a party
with those guys and then you've got a
friend is it a friend of yours who's a
psychic oh God yeah this is my favorite
bit
it's funny how one story comes out and
then it obliterates so it's one of the
defining things other actors going okay
I want to hear well look yeah I did
um meet a psychic who's a friend of mine
and I was seeing her she's got lots and
lots of different
um strings to her bones she does healing
and she does
um other things and but she also has a
um a talent for mediumship and as I was
doing seeing her for something else she
said oh Margaret is here does that mean
anything and I and I said yes it does
and I suddenly thought well I've got
before you get I've been asked a player
I hadn't actually said yes at that point
and uh I said well yeah no actually if
you've got the horse you know the
horse's mouth that's in the room you're
not going to say yes no actually you
know so and so I said um yeah and I
asked I said would you mind if I played
you
and uh she said
no she said well no she did say I I
think you're a better idea than the
other actor oh the other idea the other
you know the other who was the other
they never told me the other the other
possibility
gunshot right now
but there are it was a very typically a
typical Margaret thing you had met her I
have met her she had a she had a way
yeah a couple of times like this yeah
yeah it's either not but um
is she had us been aware of sometimes
complimenting and putting you down at
the same time she was
um and the fact that she said yeah I
think you're better than that it was
just like you never knew where you were
with her then she came through with
another note which was useful whether it
came whether it was true because the
psychic was fantastically intuitive or
there really was the Ghost of Margaret
telling me I don't I don't know but the
note was good and it says I get the
smoking right
okay and I smoked in a particular way
and always remember that the cigarette
holder is as much a weapon for
expression as anything else
and that was a good note and she was
somebody who was innately dramatic if
you're Royal you can't necessarily talk
much you're a walking icon you're a
walking so she was very she was very I
think conscious about the silhouette and
whatever she did with her body and
particularly with her hands and so you
know anyway
am I waxing no I love you
just I I you don't believe in talking
dead people
and I can't end like without talking
about probably the most iconic scene
you've been in the scene in Alien when
the creature bursts out of the the chest
John hurt's chest you've spoiled it for
me now
it's going to ruin your experience and
oh I remember we got told to be quiet
and when we went to see it because we
were screaming too much no so and you've
got to think it's meant to make you
scream we obviously overdid it slightly
um
but what kind of gang were you with gray
uh no but I read and this scene was
incredible I mean you and other cast
members talking about the filming that
in that scene with John Hurt you weren't
entirely clear about what was going to
happen we knew what happened in the
script we knew that something came out
of John hurt's chest because his line
was oh my God
and he never delivered that line
um he came up with something better but
when we got down to the set everyone was
in raincoats which should have given us
a clue we knew that this would happen
but we did not know how they would make
it happen because this was before CGI so
everything you see in the in the film is
actually happening and I I think there's
a great Master where you see the whole
cast kind of going
because something does happen it
happened effortlessly with just a few I
don't know hoses and things like that
and and we're all just astonished
because it was so real well look we
think we worked out how it was done
right yeah so we have a problem we have
a problem so if we look over and check
it out to tell us if this is how it's
done so come with me now Sandy you've
never seen the do you want to be John
Hurt I don't know is it a good thought
yes
is memorable so basically this is I take
this off here we go like that
yeah
so you hop on there and you put your
little not little you're just your arms
there you go
my arm's in here there we go into the
little sleeves there okay
is this
it's exactly the way it was yeah oh
exactly oh
she's humorous
that's not even very good no no
what but no if you get into your
character he's having we're having
breakfast and suddenly he starts
coughing right and he can't stop
coughing and then suddenly something
starts to burst out of his chest and uh
okay so that's exactly in the end he's
in terrible pain we're going a bit
hysterical is this nice yes okay so
you're thrashing around just move a leg
backwards
[Applause]
not bad